Richard Roeper Chicago sun-times
nationally syndicated columnist movie
critic and his new podcast the best
movies ongoing series with various
episodes including a six-part series on
the best movies of the decade upcoming
series on the best James Bond movies
follow him on Twitter at Richard Roeper
hi Richard Dan always good to talk to
you how you doing I'm great give me the
movie in the last five years Academy
Award nominated movie that you would
watch over and over oh wow
last five years over and over myself
my first thought is the movie I never
want to see again which would be
Bohemian Rhapsody being a critic of
course I always go in the opposite
direction we talked about repeatability
I'd say the movie in the last five years
that I'd watched over and over is a
movie from 2019 Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood it's the type of movie you can
you know you could drop in anytime it's
like a Scorsese film you know a
Goodfellas anything like that any moment
of Once Upon a Time in Hollywood is a
brilliant scene why did turn Tino
continue to drag out all of the scenes
well I think when you got a good thing
going you keep going with it that's sort
of like asking why did let's up what
makes their way to have an eight and a
half minutes I like that pacing dan and
I know with with Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood and certainly with the
Irishman some people get a little
fidgety because the scenes don't cut
like normal movies do or I should say
typical movies do these day I like it
what a movie gives us seen a chance to
breathe I'll give you that because you
got a lot you could have cut that movie
by 30 minutes and nobody would have
missed anything there you look he's a
brilliant filmmaker and I always you
know love to watch what he does in the
craft that he has with it but it just
felt like there were there was a scene
that you go okay then it ends or it
should end and then all of a sudden it
continued as the little girl talks to
Leonardo DiCaprio and then it goes on
and on
go alright but and and Brad Pitt's
probably winning an Academy Award right
he's definitely gonna win dad and you
know here's the thing with Brad Pitt out
of the Supporting Actor nominees this
year he's the only one that doesn't have
an acting victory and acting Oscar and
he's really really good and once upon a
time in Hollywood as you know it's
really a co-lead you know he and Leo are
cold leads in the movie they put legal
up for lead and then Brad up or
supporting but he's a popular guy he's a
guy everyone likes to work with and I
thought it was actually kind of a
perfect marriage between the guys
on-screen persona and the role that
Tarantino clearly intended for Brad Pitt
to have he was funny and I think that
sometimes when you see somebody not
playing to what you think their
character is that's why he stood out
like he had a sort of a goofy guy and
yeah you're absolutely right he has a
goofy guy he's a guy you know the
DiCaprio character there you guys are in
parallel paths in their lives the cap
Rio's character feels like his b-level
career as an actor is coming to an end
whereas Brad Pitt has long come to terms
with the fact that he was never going to
be a star he's just the stunt man turned
glorified gofer and he's okay with that
he's gonna enjoy life he's gonna have a
beer he's gonna meet women and and just
have a good time
well my guys are kind of split on the
Irishman I I got bored by it well you
know I hear this for people a lot and
like you know like you know people were
very intimidated by the running time it
does have a certain deliberate pace you
know as someone who sees 350 movies a
year and so many of them are caught to
appeal to the attention deficit disorder
generation and they do exactly the same
and they move it exactly but you're
right you know I know I know exactly
when they're gonna cut to the next scene
in I know how they're gonna use the
visual punch line and I like it and I
you know listen I understand what people
are saying but when people say to me hey
listen man I can't watch the Irish
murder one thing I'm like but she'll
binge watch all six seasons of shits
Creek without ever getting out of bed so
watch six n-c-double-a basketball games
on a February
Saturday without saying it's too long so
it's all a matter of what you're
interested in seeing yeah but shits
Creek is better than the irishman though
here are the two best movies this year
you ready I'm ready
parasite and Jojo rabbit I'm not gonna
disagree either one of those and he's
interesting you pick you know you pick
two films that are way outside the norm
obviously parasites being a foreign
language film and really having some
great stuff and then Jojo rabbit in this
era we you know we talked about
everybody being politically correct and
afraid to take chances and here's a
movie about a ten year old boy with
hitlerism as an imaginary friend talk
about a bold move I love both of those
zones yeah I just thought and I think
Scarlett Johansson has had an
unbelievable a year you know I loved her
more than Adam driver in marriage story
I thought she was spectacular in there
but yeah she was great you know it's
interesting too
she's never been nominated for an Oscar
before and now she's got the double the
daily doubles lead actress and
supporting actors I think a lot of
people thought oh she must have been
nominated for lost in translation but no
she never was nominated so this year she
was great in lost in translation but you
know Bill Murray's character was so big
that I'm surprised she what nominate is
Best Supporting Actress yeah I think
most people just assumed that she had
been and you mentioned Jojo rabbit what
I loved about her performance there Dan
was Scarlett has often played you know
she plays the Black Widow or she plays
these kind of almost ice Queens and then
Jojo rabbit she's a mom she's a mother
in the most trying of circumstances and
I thought it was her warmest and most
empathetic performance the look okay so
who wins best movie is gonna be it's
gonna be 1917 but varascite and Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood still have an
outside shot okay Best Actor Joaquin
Phoenix for sure he's your mortal lock
you know he's like yo Lamar Jackson for
MVP this year was a foregone conclusion
a [ __ ] when it's a great performance I
hated the ending of that movie though
yeah talk show thing with De Niro I
it just dragged in and it you had so
much tension and you knew what that
something was gonna happen there but it
just took forever and I you know I was
okay with the very end with the total
anarchy but the talkshow portion of that
I was I was bored dinero didn't even
seem like he was the right person for
that role hey you know what the
polarizing film and Nero I think it was
a double-edged sword there because so
much of that sound was clearly based on
taxi driver and King of Comedy which are
too obvious you know a huge De Niro
films so the casting felt a little bit
like Sun casting I you know I see what
you're being kind of tricky out of the
movie a little bit I just thought that
the joaquin phoenix is wonderful in
there I don't know why he had to show
that he lost all this weight or he's
really skinny cuz it's not like that had
anything to do with his role but he
takes off his shirt or ass his shirt off
one time you go it's not like you're
putting it you know this isn't Raging
Bull here or something it had nothing to
do with his character yeah I'm over all
of the radical weight gains and losses
for me and then we get the inevitable
stories from the beautiful actress or
the hunky dude talking about what a
sacrifice they made and you know this
classic coke quote that Laurence Olivier
gave to Dustin Hoffman on the set of
Marathon Man when he told her wanting to
try acting it's so much easier so the
Best Supporting is going to be Brad Pitt
best actor you already said best yeah
best actress Renee Zellweger for beauty
right I thought I went to see it there
is a scene at the very end where I
thought she was her I thought that she
had actually become her and it's what
you know at the very end when she's
melting down and she wants her one last
chance on stage I I thought that she was
great in a movie that I didn't think was
great yeah any other nominations at the
other category I think it's a classic
example of how much Hollywood loves
itself about itself so she's gonna win I
I didn't love the performance honestly I
know it was a good impersonation not a
great performance the movie in 2020 that
we should definitely see
well there's a lot of great stuff coming
out right now you know in the near
horizon and I have another Sandler movie
coming out in 2020 I just want to let
you know I play as did Sandler get job
here yes first of all he did I thought
it was a great performance
I also thought that kevin garnett
playing a stylized version of kevin
garnett gave one of the best
performances and athlete has ever given
in a movie wasn't he terrific I mean it
was about him he's so menacing as he has
done uncork a lot of times you know as a
player but you know very dark wicked
sense of humor I think that movie I just
deserve multiple Oscar nomination okay
because your best Green Planet Best
Director yeah the best acting by an
athlete in a movie is who I mean you
mean ever any Ally I'm just curious an
actor I'm you know rippling through and
rifling through all of you I mean
depends on what we call you know who was
it who was really an athlete because a
lot of these guys played a little
college ball like you know Burt Reynolds
and and Kris Kristofferson and people
like that you get to a certain point
where you know are they've considered
more actors or athletes and you know I
don't know honestly off the top of my
head I can't say who act is the absolute
best performance by an athlete cream was
pretty good cream was pretty good an
airplane cream is good you know those
rolls and cream is good those rolls are
served up though you know again I mean
it's when you see again you know you see
somebody like you know
Garnett who's actually asked to play
something and actually you know really a
participant in the film and not a
glorified cameo or more impressed by
that it's great to talk to you Richard
thanks for joining us as always and I
love to have you back on again
I'd love to come on again Danna just one
classified you realize with your movie
critiques you're starting to sound like
the dad in the back row of the theater
you do realize that at this point right
you know they're too long that's a point
one wait a minute but I just gave you
parasite in Jojo rabbit that's not the
dad that's
cutting-edge movie critic right there
that was your redeeming moment I am gene
Shalit with the jump shot is what I am
there's another quote thank you Richard
that's Richard Roeper Chicago sun-times
you can follow him on at Richard E Roper
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]